ouverture des centres de loisirs jusqu'à
19h création d'une équipe de médiateurs
pour la tranquillité publique en fin de
journée nocturne de l'accueil mairie
jusqu'à 20 heures
les premières propositions concrètes de
la liste vivre et décider ensemble porté
par jean yves blé un programme global
pour la ville de la verrière
on veut relancer une attractivité pour
notre ville notre ville se meurt
les gens partent ne veut pas y rester
on le voit on discute avec les gens on
est à l'affût de des besoins du
bien-être de nos habitants que ce soit
dans le quartier du bois les temps que
ce soit au village ou à orly parc et
pour le futur quartier gare de cannes
en plus des projets d'aménagement d'orly
parquet des bécanes il y à la rénovation
du quartier du bois de l'étang
jean yves blais porte un programme de
démolition partielle la destruction
d'environ 180 logements soit un bâtiment
revoir les appartements aussi puisque
une réhabilitation c'est ça passe aussi
par les a les habitants à l'intérieur
avec une priorité de ceux qui restent et
puis avec une charte de relogement qui
sera signée avec les habitants où on
garantit qu'ils seront relogés là où il
le souhaite
on peut penser par exemple à réunir les
deux écoles qui aujourd'hui vous avez
une école maternelle dans un quoi et
puis un groupe scolaire de l'autre autre
point du programme pour les habitants
sans complémentaire la mairie pourrait
négocier des prix attractifs auprès des
mutuelles une mesure au coeur des
échanges de la réunion sur la santé
prévue mercredi 22 janvier à 19 heures
au scarabée